[Music]
well hello dear friends welcome to our
program i'd like to know
this is a question and answer program
which
airs every week for half an hour and
we're glad that you decided to join us
today we have some very interesting
questions
um i want to invite you to please
take out your bibles because this is a
program based
on holy scripture james rafferty will be
joining us momentarily
he had a last-minute thing that he had
to take care of
but he'll be with us momentarily we want
to begin with the word of prayer
and then we'll get right into the
questions that were sent to us so let's
pray
father in heaven we thank you for the
privilege now of
opening your word and studying your word
we ask that you will bless us as we
answer these questions
we ask lord that you will bless those
who have asked the questions
and that what we study from your word
will be useful not only for our
intellectual knowledge
but also for our daily walk with the
lord we thank you for being with us and
for answering our prayer
for we ask it in jesus name amen
i just want to mention that if you want
to send us your questions
you can do so at the address that you're
going to see on the screen
tv at some tv dot org
once again tv at some tv dot
org you can see it there on the screen
uh send us your questions
and we will do the research and do
everything within our power
to answer the questions that you send us
so
i want to just read the first question
that we have it's a very interesting one
it says the following please show me
where it says in the writings of ellen
white
that the day begins at sunset
and also that she was ever shown in any
vision
uh told by an angel that saturday
is the sabbath so you have two questions
here one
is uh what proof do we have from the
writings of ellen white
that the day begins at sunset and
the other question is was she ever shown
in vision
that saturday is the sabbath and i see
that uh
james rafferty is here with us praise
the lord he had a last-minute thing that
was urgent and needed taken care of but
he's with us now so let me repeat the
question
um and i did pray with you and you were
praying i was out there getting ready
and
praise the lord well that's good uh yeah
the um
the questions are two number one how do
we know from the writings of ellen white
that the day begins at sunset
and the other question is uh did an
angel ever reveal to her
that saturday's the sabbath okay and
what what we probably should do
is start with what the bible says and
then maybe go
to the writings of illinois because
they're in harmony so
what evidence do we have in the bible
that the sabbath begins at sunset
and that the sabbath is
the seventh day well right from the very
beginning i mean genesis chapter 1
and 2 orders our days orders our weeks
uh you know it's interesting
pastor that the weekly cycle of all the
cycles
uh that we have the weekly cycle is not
based on you know the solar system the
sun the moon the stars the lunar
it's it's it's uniquely established in
genesis
uh the weekly cycle was established in
the creation week
right one two three four five six seven
one two three four five six seven and
it's been that way all the way through
people have tried to change that cycle
but it doesn't change there's no way to
change it because i think in a sense
because we're made in the image of god
and the weekly cycle ends with the
sabbath which is part of god's law it's
built into us
right that that whole dynamic is built
into us so
as you go through genesis chapter one
and chapter two you have this creation
week
and each one of these days ends
with this evening and morning evening
and
morning evening and morning that's where
we get the whole idea
of when the day starts when the day ends
sunset to sunset sunset to sunset now of
course you know we
as humans are on the cycle where 12
o'clock midnight
is the end of the previous day and 1201
is the new day
and that's okay that's fine but from a
biblical perspective
and it's really significant when you
start looking at some of the new
testament verses that talk about maybe
the first day of the week or what was
going on at certain times like early in
the
before the sun rose early on sunday
morning they went to the tomb and jesus
was gone and you could say well that
wasn't sunday yet you know but
uh or it was i should say but sunday
actually starts or
sabbath actually ends at sun sentence
and the next day actually starts at
sunrise
which kind of actually gives some good
um understanding to some of these
questionable texts yeah so um
so the fact that genesis chapter 2 tells
us in verses 2 and 3
on the seventh day god ended his work
which he had done
and he rested on the seventh day from
all his work which he had done
then god blessed the seventh day i think
he wants us to know that the sabbath is
the seventh day
okay and in the fourth commandment it's
repeated twice
that the seventh day is the sabbath okay
the lord your god so
very clearly apart from what ellen white
says which she confirms
the bible clearly teaches that the
seventh day of the week is sabbath and
there's no evidence
that the weekly cycle has ever been
changed okay
maybe a new testament text also mark
chapter 1 and verse 32.
clearly shows us that the sabbath ends
at sunset
okay this is you know people wanted
jesus to
heal the sick it says there
that jesus waited sometimes to not
totally aggravate the pharisees okay
he waited until the sabbath was over so
you want to read that
mark 1 32 32 all right
and it even when the sun did set they
brought unto him all that were diseased
and all that were possessed with devils
and all the city was gathered together
at the door and he healed many
that were sick of different diseases and
cast out many devils that suffered not
the devils to speak
because they knew him so yeah that's so
when is the evening when the sun sets
very clearly and and you're right the
context was
that he was being um accused of healing
on the sabbaths and so the people
themselves
jesus taught that it was okay to heal on
sabbath but to avoid controversy
and because of the people's fear of the
religious leaders they waited until
sunset until the sabbath was passed he
did do some sabbath
healings that aggravated the religious
leaders
but he didn't want to uh he didn't want
to aggravate them over
uh so much that it would interfere with
his ministry
okay now what about ellen white we
thought basically covered some bible
points but
do we have anything in ellen white that
uh shows that she believed that
sabbath begins at sunset and uh that the
seventh day
uh is the sabbath well there's a number
of statements maybe you have
a couple there there's a number of
statements from her writings that
clarifies this you know the believers
the early believers
set a time and that time was six they
just felt like this is the time we're
just gonna set it it's gonna be from six
to six
even to even mean six to six and
even ellen white she was given a vision
concerning the start
on the end of the sabbath and she
herself felt that that vision was in
in harmony with the sixth to sixth time
but she was actually instructed by an
angel that it wasn't
right and she accepted and she accepted
that instruction
right and there's a number of references
for this um
i have one reference here that i could
give um just
its um life's experiences
um of ellen white page 55 that's one
reference that you could look up
for this where the whole thing is
clarified from the first vision all the
way through
to the clarification of the angel you
know it's interesting ellen white
she got her at least her an original
conviction about the sabbath from joseph
bates
he was a sea captain he was converted he
was a little skeptical about her being a
prophet seeing visions but he was
hoping actually maybe this was true and
wanted some verification
and he was the one that introduced the
idea of not just the sabbath but the six
to six idea
and until she had that vision that was
later clarified by the angel
that's what sabbath keepers did and it's
really interesting because one sabbath
on a friday they started at six
yeah and that next day they ended at
sunset and some people at that time kept
the sabbath from sunrise to sunrise too
okay so there was a lot of confusion
going on about when the sabbath actually
began but
you know she trusted joseph bates
because he knew a lot about astronomy
and of course he was wrong and he
recognized that he was wrong and he also
began keeping the sabbath at sunset like
the bible says
maybe i can just read a couple of
statements here uh this is um
from manuscript releases uh she's
talking about
uh you know how the sabbath can be kept
in the polar regions where the sun
where the sun never sits or where it's
dark depending on the season
right here for 20 hours a day you know
several years ago i
i would had the privilege of going to
gnome alaska in january
uh it was amazing you know the the
darkness
for 20 hours really 20 hours yeah in the
summer of course
uh you know there's a light for 20 hours
that's a very short sabbath like maybe
four hours or
yeah but how does that see here's here's
the point
god rested on the seventh day and set it
apart for man to observe
in honor of his creation of the heavens
and the earth in six literal days
he blessed and sanctified and made made
holy the day of rest
when men are so careful to search and
dig to see in regard to the precise
period of time
we are to say god made his sabbath for a
round world
so that gets rid of the idea that uh
earth is square
right and flat so god made the sabbath
for a round world
and when the seventh day comes to us of
course
it would we have to be a round world for
the sabbath to come to us
in that round world controlled by the
sun that rules the day
not the moon it is the time in
all countries and lands to observe the
sabbath
in the countries where there is no
sunset for months
and again no sunrise for months the
period of time will be calculated by
records kept
so astronomical records can help for to
know when
i can make it very clear so that we
don't have to be in that in that
confusion that's what i love about the
spirit of prophecy
a lot of clarity to help us you know as
we're moving through some of these
issues and one more quotation this one
comes from letter
31 1898 god made the world in six
literal days
and on the seventh literal day he rested
from all his work which he had done
and was refreshed so she he has given
human beings six days in which to labor
by thus setting apart the sabbath god
gave the world a memorial
he did not set apart one day and any day
in seven
but one particular day the seventh day
and by observing the sabbath we show
that we recognize god
as the living god the creator of heaven
and earth so she very clearly says that
the week is composed of seven days and
the seventh day is the sabbath amen
and christian experience and teaching is
another reference i won't read it but
it's page 86
christian experience and teaching where
she talks about that
clarification with joseph bates and the
vision of the angel etc
that really helped to settle him into
that evening from evening
evening being sunset to sunset well i
think we've answered that
question satisfactorily i hope so anyway
now i want to go to a somewhat
controversial and touchy
question okay please i want to know
whether wearing
of earrings bracelets
and rings on the finger will prevent one
from going to heaven
kindly educate me on that did people
like david and solomon
wear rings and bracelets so
i'm going to throw that one to you okay
well first of all it's an easy answer
for david and solomon yes
yeah david and solomon probably wore
jewelry
um david you know salma also had 700
wives and 300 concubines
there were things that you'll find in
the old testament that were not
what god wanted from the beginning you
know
matthew 19 is a really powerful
principle that jesus brings out and you
know the pharisees are trying to catch
him you know and trip him up and they
say well is it okay to divorce your wife
for any reason
right and then he says well no and and
they say well why did moses say that we
could divorce our wives you know and
he said yes moses did that because of
the hardness of your hearts right but
from the beginning it wasn't so
and so when we look at some of these
principles sometimes we go to the bible
and we just
pick whatever we want and say well you
know
back here david had three wives so i
guess it's okay for me to have three
wives
he was a man after god's own heart you
know and we need to recognize that god
is working with humanity down through
the
uh ages where they are he's meeting us
where we are
but as we move toward the final
end of sin and suffering god is bringing
a people back to the original
that's why we talked about genesis 1 and
2 revelation 21-22
and god's original goal to get us back
so
if you look at that from that
perspective
there is in the book of revelation a
really clear answer to this question
it's in revelation 12 in comparison to
revelation 17.
so in revelation 12 you have a picture
of a woman which represents a church
and this woman is pure she's not wearing
jewelry and gold whatever she has a gold
crown which symbolizes
12 stars which symbolizes the
organizational structure of the church
12 as an organization
basically it has a function over and
above adornment
yes there you go good perfect and then
you've got a woman
in revelation 17 and she is decked out
gold pearls rings etc now the woman in
revelation 12
represents god's church god's pure
church from which we have a remnant keep
the commandments of god and have the
faith of jesus
and they look just like her because of
the remnant of her and then you have
this woman
in revelation 17 who i identifies as the
mother of harlot so she has a lot of
daughter churches
and all of these churches along with
this harlot church
are decked out and that's exactly what
you see in the world today
so if you want a clear revelation you've
got a lot of churches
a mother church and a lot of other
churches that are decked out with
jewelry versus
this pure woman that has no jewelry
except for that crown that has a
function
symbolizing organizational structure and
i think that's the clearest revelation
when i
ever give a sermon on jewelry i just say
okay let's just look at god's church
as it's depicted in the last chapter as
we're moving toward the end of time
you know it's interesting that as time
has gone by
christian women more and more adorn
themselves and paint themselves up
and use more jewelry than ever before
you know i remember when i was a kid
and i went uh once in a while to with my
dad to
some sunday service for some special
function
that he was invited to the women dressed
very modestly
and there was very little jewelry in the
church
but as time has gone by um you know
it's totally different these days
and we see this i think because we're
moving in a certain direction
there's a key principle that i've always
appreciated
just to give some counter balance to
this
because i think a lot of people have
made jewelry the
issue of their sermonizing and doctrines
and teaching and they're just
hammering people on this and if they're
not wearing certain things and acting a
certain way then you know
they're going to hell in the handbasket
so to speak and
in evangelism on page 372 no 272
ellen white has this principle that just
has been such a blessing to me
in dealing with this subject and she
talks about people who
pick off the ornaments and whatever
seems offensive and tell people you
shouldn't dress that way you shouldn't
wear that
and she says that's like pulling leaves
off a living tree
the leaves will just reappear again she
says the ax needs to be laid at the root
of the tree that's what john the baptist
did right
and the way he did it was he said behold
the lamb of god that takes away the sins
of the world
and elohim says the same thing we need
to talk about jesus we need to reveal
his spirit
and reveal his love and she says then
the axe is laid at the rid of the tree
and the leaves will never appear they'll
fall off and they won't appear again
right and so what we need in all of
these standards in the church the key to
it
is directing people to christ once the
heart is one and once the heart is
converted then it is that all these
things start falling off that's the way
it worked in my life not that i was
wearing jewelry but i had the
accessories i had all the stuff
that was really it was my security you
know you have these things because it
makes you feel secure
you're somebody so to speak but when you
find jesus
you don't need all that fluffy stuff on
the outside the interesting thing is
though
going one step beyond that is that many
people who love jesus
just don't understand the issue of
jewelry
and so there's still room for
instruction in other words you'll say
just love jesus and you know
you'll do everything automatically right
there has to be instruction it's like
children
you know you have to instruct children
even if they love their parents they're
not going to do
everything that they're supposed to do
yes they need to be instructed
what it means to love the lord jesus
you know it influences what we eat it
influences how we dress
it influences how we use our time what
we watch what we listen to
when we're converted sometimes little by
little all of those things are taken
care of but there needs to be
instruction
absolutely on that particular point
without falling into the era of legalism
and the bible has an instruction in fact
first peter chapter three i don't know
if you want to look at those verses
i have those two paul peter and paul
good authorities new testament okay so
first peter chapter 3
and i think versus two through
um five first speed of three two through
five
he says
i'll just start at the beginning because
for the context likewise you wise be in
subjection to your own husbands
that if any obey not the word they also
may without the word be won by your
conversation by the conversation of the
wives
or the conduct the conduct yeah the
conversation being the cop james
while they behold your chase
conversation or conduct
manner of life or behavior deportment is
what the greek
is indicating there coupled with fear
who's adorning
let not be with the outward adorning of
plating of the hair and wearing of gold
and putting on of apparel
but verse 4 let it be the hidden man of
the heart
in that which is not corruptable even
the ornament of a meek and quiet spirit
which is in the sight of god of great
price for after this manner in the old
time
the holy women also who trusted in god
had joined themselves adorned themselves
excuse me being in subjection unto their
own husbands
absolutely clear yeah these verses are
really clear they're beautiful
they're talking about the spirit of
meekness
subjection they're talking about your
god the conversation etc
in replacement of all of the jewelry and
that's
attractive and it leads uh
us to a whole different way of relating
to one another when we see that kind of
an attitude that kind of a spirit
in in a woman it leads husbands who may
not even be obedient
it leads them or draws them to the lord
uh yeah yeah there's one little thing
that we need to
mention in this passage and that is it
gives the impression that you can use
outward adornment the important thing is
to have a good heart
okay uh because it says in verse three
do not let your adornment be
merely outward okay but the word merely
is added to the text
it's in italics in the king james
version so
so we need to take away that word merely
okay
uh and simply say let do not let your
adornment
be outward arranging the hair wearing
gold etc
where's that merely at i didn't see that
well i have it in my new king james
version and i
i don't know if it's in your king james
it's not in my king james no no
no yeah the new king james it is okay so
they've got a little bit
added in there gotcha okay that's all
right that's the reason why you have to
compare different versions that's right
we talked about that earlier that's
right we talked about talked about that
in the sabbath school class and you've
got to have your king james at least for
reference right
there you go there you go okay uh first
timothy two
okay let's go to that passage uh verses
eight through ten
first timothy 2 8-10 the apostle paul
agreed with peter
okay i'll read that sure i will
therefore that men
pray everywhere lifting up holy hands
without wrath and doubting
and in like manner also that women adorn
themselves in modest apparel with
shame-facedness and sobriety not with
broided hair or gold or pearls or costly
array
but that which becomes women professing
godliness with good works
so it's the good works that really show
the character of the person
not all the external adornment right
that's key
it's hard though you know we're living
in a society where there's a lot of
emphasis as we're moving toward the end
of time
a lot more emphasis is put on the
outward you know and there's a lot of
superficiality
taking place you know a lot of media
emphasis taking place
and so i know this can be challenging
but the heart is really where it's at
and for those
viewers who are struggling with this uh
what you want to do is you don't want to
just immediately
say i'm just going to take all my
jewelry off you want to say no i want to
get my heart connected with christ i
want
him to be the one that renews my heart
and transforms me
and i want him to be the means the power
by which this transition takes place
because then you take it all off just
like that
we set red in evangelism 272. it's just
like picking leaves off a living tree it
could all just come back on again
[Music]
maybe i can read we only have like a few
minutes left but i can read
actually a passage from the book of
enoch
now enoch is not inspired but
it's very interesting that this passage
is actually describing
uh what genesis 6 has where it says that
the sons of god
saw that the daughters of men were
beautiful okay
and um you know this is from enoch
chapter eight and verse one
also chapter nine in verse six chapter
ten and verses four through six it's a
combination of different
texts you know of course the sons of god
saw that the daughters of men were very
beautiful and so they took wives from
among them
but what was it that attracted the sons
of god according to the book of enoch
you know were there not also daughters
of god that were beautiful why did they
have to look at the daughters of men
that were beautiful okay
well the fact is that the daughters of
god were ordinary
whereas the the daughters of men were
all decked out
really listen to this statement from the
book of enoch
of course they believe that the sons of
god were angels that mingled with you
but over and above that point okay uh it
says
azazel which is satan is represented in
the book of enoch as the leader of the
rebellious giants
in the time preceding the flood he
taught men the art of warfare
of making swords knives shields
and coats of mail and women the art of
deception
by ornamenting the body dying the hair
and painting the face
and the eyebrows and also revealed to
the people the secrets of witchcraft
and corrupted their manners leading them
into wickedness and impurity
until at last he was at the lord's
command
bound hand and foot that's azel by the
archangel raphael
and chained to the rough and jagged rot
rocks of judael
where he is to abide in utter darkness
until the great day of judgment
when he will be cast into the fire to be
consumed forever
also in a couple of passages
from the talmud and
the talmud of reuben chapter five in
verses five through seven
uh it says flee for therefore flee
fornication my children
and command your wives and your
daughters that they adorn
not their heads and faces to deceive the
mind
because every woman who uses these wiles
hath been reserved for eternal
punishment for thus they alert the
watchers who were before the flood
and then one more of course we know that
that wasn't angels that they mingled
with it was the
the sons of god were the faithful ones
the faithful ones
uh the other one is targum of pseudo
jonathan chapter six verses one to two
and it came to pass when the sons of men
began to multiply in the face of the
ground
and beautiful daughters were born to
them that the sons of the great ones saw
that the daughters of men were beautiful
with eyes painted and hair curled
walking the nakedness of flesh
and they conceived lustful thoughts and
they took them wives of all they chose
okay so it wasn't just the makeup it was
the apparel yeah so in jewish tradition
in jewish tradition there's this idea
that
you know that women need to dress
modestly and don't don't need to look
like a christmas tree
all adored yeah and part of that is
deception in other words that
is that kind of dress that is immodest
is a deceptive uh apparel and that's
what you find in revelation 17.
right you know there's a couple of
abominations in the in the
hand of this woman that's uh labels
babylon with the harlot daughters
and she's got the filthiness of her
fornication in there
and deception deceiving the kings of
this earth and she is dressed scantily
and
and decked with gold and silver and etc
well there's a lot more that we could
say about this i have a bunch of other
verses from the old testament but our
time is just about up
i want to remind you that if you have
questions
that you please send the questions to us
you know you saw it on the screen at the
beginning of the program the
electronic address is tv at some tv.org
there it is on the screen tv at some tv
dot org
and we'll do the research and if the
question has an
answer we'll certainly try to find it
and we'll share the answers with you
here
on this program i'd like to know we also
have a spanish program i'd like to know
and so we encourage those who speak
spanish to tune in as well
thank you once again for joining us we
look forward to having you once again
in our next program i'd like to know
[Music]
you